qué grado de aprobación a nivel Estatal
están teniendo las movilizaciones contra
el gobierno de boluarte
bien a nivel de país podemos mencionar
que estas protestas están teniendo una
gran resonancia sobre todo en el
interior del país en donde ha calado
mayormente esta movilización que ha sido
que es importante
denominada la toma de Lima tras la cual
muchos manifestantes están viajando como
se ha podido ver en imágenes que ya
dieron la vuelta al mundo
en camino hacia la capital Lima
metropolitana y donde incluso trasciende
que se estarían
hospedando en la universidad más
importante a nivel Estatal es de
Universidad Nacional mayor de San Marcos
y el anterior gobierno de Castillo tenía
un alto grado de desaprobación pero era
aún mayor en el caso del Congreso con
esta premisa unas nuevas elecciones
solucionarían algo en el país o se
requieren cambios más profundos
definitivamente se requieren cambios
mucho más profundos y no los que por
fuera podrían realizarse y de momento
porque sería una cuestión mucho más
popular antes eh políticamente adecuada
y correcta es sin embargo los
manifestantes requieren de un esfuerzo y
de una solución rápida o por lo menos de
un gesto un gesto por ejemplo podría ser
la renuncia de la presidenta pero ella
no está dispuesto hasta el momento
acceder y por otro lado el parlamento
pasa por una situación política tensa en
donde su desaprobación termina siendo
importante y también muchos de estos
manifestantes requieren que el
parlamento se vaya incluso a unas nuevas
elecciones Igualmente que la presidenta
sin tomar por supuesto en cuenta que
logísticamente prepararon un nuevo
proceso electoral de todos modos
requiriendo un tiempo determinado que va
alrededor de un año para poder
prepararse adecuadamente y que
evidentemente esta no tenga
cuestionamientos que finalmente la
deslegitimen habla usted de la
presidenta dinavoluarte y de la futura
cita electoral Cuál es su aprobación
ahora mismo de Cara a esta cita y dentro
del país por las protestas
sus niveles de aprobación del actual
presidente son bastante bajos van
alrededor del 30% en resumen según las
investigaciones y los índices de
desaprobación terminan siendo
importantes si bien es cierto pueden
estar un poco superiores a los de Pedro
Castillo en la actualidad esto es muy
grave de Cara a a la popularidad que
ella pueda tener para confrontar estas
protestas que tienen una representación
de esta mayoría de peruanos